the great Andrew Breitbart told us that
politics is downstream of culture and of
course he was right in a sense pop
culture has dictated plenty of political
transformations over the years from
public opinions on socialism to
redefining marriage but politics affects
culture too as a banana duct-taped to a
wall sells for $120,000 at Art Basel as
drag queen story our hits preschools and
as kids get hooked on hardcore internet
porn before the age of 10
libertarians be where we examine whether
politics can help fix our screwed up
culture too then speaking of bad
politics and creepy sex disgraced former
congressman Katie hill publishes an
op-ed in the shameless New York Times
which we will analyze as the dumbest
article on the internet today all that
and more I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
all right welcome to our new set we've
been waiting for our new set for about
55 years now I think we are on it very
exciting that's the good news here
there's a lot of good news in Washington
at the White House bad news on the
Capitol for Democrats and all of this
actually tells us a little bit about our
culture the impeachment hearings the way
that's going actually does relate
$220,000 bananas and drag queens story
hour and internet porn people figure out
how in a second first we just have to
mention the the really great news for
the White House because obviously no one
else is gonna do that at CNN or MSNBC or
increasingly even on ostensibly
right-wing sources so last week's
impeachment hearings trainwreck right
don't believe the spin from The
Washington Post or anybody else an
absolute disaster for Democrats the
impeachment inquiry hearings didn't come
up with any evidence that Trump
committed wrongdoing then you had those
three awful professors one was less
likable than the next and the only one
who had any sense was Jonathan Turley
who's actually a liberal law professor
though he was called by the Republicans
and he pointed out in a really calm
erudite ironclad way that the Democrats
don't have nothing on President Trump
you don't need to take my word for that
you don't need to just accept and say oh
Michael is putting spin on this for the
president it isn't just me even Jake
Tapper even CNN believes that last
week's impeachment hearings were a train
wreck tapper is now asking Nancy Pelosi
if she's afraid that she ended up
helping Trump with the impeachment she's
asking if she will regret the
impeachment process if the impeachment
process ends up helping Trump it looks
right now like it will help Trump and
what does Nancy Pelosi gonna say she's
not going to say yeah you're right Chuck
we made a huge or yeah you're right
whatever his name is Jake we made a huge
mistake we never should have initiated
the impeachment hearings no she's not
gonna do that she's gonna double down
but her response is just not believable
if you wake up the day after election
day 22
and exit polls show that impeaching
President Trump helped him get reelected
would you have any regrets no other said
this isn't about politics at all this is
about patriotism it's not about
partisanship it's about honoring our
oath of office this is the first
president has committed all of these
things as the constitutional experts
said yesterday nobody ever even come
close not Richard Nixon even came close
to his dishonor in his own oath of
office so no this isn't a politics is
not even a consideration in this this is
about protect and defend the
Constitution you know it is actually
impressive that somebody could tell such
an obvious and egregious lie as the
impeachment of Donald Trump has nothing
to do with politics the impeachment that
we've been pushing for for now for
different reasons the first three of
which failed and the fourth is probably
going to fail too since before he even
took office yeah it has nothing to do
with politics it is impressive that
someone could be in politics so long to
become so cynical
to be able to tell an absolutely
egregious lie with a straight face but
you can see even in the way Pelosi is
talking she stammers a little bit she
holds up she's even for her and she is
so passed shame on this it's a little
difficult to get it out she says well it
looked Jake this has nothing to do with
politics this is about how he's so he's
so much worse than Nixon it the implicit
question here is how is he worse than
Nixon what did he do she never gives an
answer in all of the things that he did
you know from the first thing to that
other the thing he did after that and
then finally the third thing it was
almost worse than the first two
well how about you name them Nancy
except you can't because all of the
charges that you've made treason bribery
extortion this have been completely
knocked down there's no no evidence of
it whatsoever she might as well go back
to Russia collusion we had a two and a
half year thirty million dollar
investigation into that came up with
nothing but go back at least
at least that one has a specific charge
this is what bribery how how is what he
did driver they got nothing right so
Nancy Pelosi does her best to stammer
through this representative Al Green one
of my favorite members of Congress this
Democrat who just he keeps saying the
things that they're not supposed to be
saying like Al Green said at the very
beginning of Trump's I think it was just
after he'd been elected but maybe not
even before he was sworn in he said yeah
we got to impeach this guy then it was
slightly after he got sworn in he says
yeah we got to impeach him why I don't
know we got to impeach him because if we
don't impeach him he's gonna get
reelected he just keeps it being
accidentally honest about the Democrats
plans Al Green knows that all of the
current charges against the President or
so vague so nebulous they're not real so
Al Green has a new argument for
impeachment the new argument is that we
have to impeach Trump to deal with
slavery I know that you introduced one
of those first impeachment resolutions
against Trump and let's look at how that
went down it actually lost 364 to 58 how
do you think this process ends if more
evidence is revealed and are you
concerned at all that Americans are
having a waning interest as this process
drags on well it was yesterday
in fact that we celebrated in a sense
that we we had something that was
brought to the floor
I do believe ma'am that we have to deal
with the original sin we have to deal
with slavery a slavery was the thing
that put all of what President Trump has
done lately into motion until we deal
with the issue of invidious
discrimination as it relates to LGBTQ
community the anti-semitism the racism
the Islamophobia the transphobia and
also the misogyny that he has
exemplified I don't think our work is
done oh okay yeah that makes sense so
they don't have them on Ukraine they
don't have him on Russia they don't have
him on taxes they don't have him on
stormy Daniel
so now we need to impeach Trump because
of slavery what what about the
the other 44 presidents you gonna
impeach them over slavery nope just
Trump we need to wait we've had slavery
in America we had slavery beginning in
the 17th century and we had it up until
the mid 19th century and then we didn't
have it anymore after that and then we
had to wait about 150 years and then we
needed to impeach the 45th president to
deal with slavery and that is such a
ridiculous statement that I think Al
Green heard it in his head so then he
corrected it even during the statement
he said and also racism sexism misogyny
homophobia transphobia folk phobophobia
phobia ism phobia ism we need to impeach
Trump for phobia ISM they can't nail him
on any actual impeachable offense so
it's just all this vague neologisms were
new words that have been created for an
ideological purpose all of which amount
to orange man bad now this is at the
same time that Trump got some pretty
good news on the political front this
week and the good news on the political
front is actually affecting the cultural
front before we get to that I've got to
thank our friends over at route
insurance the thing about car insurance
is that good drivers subsidize bad
drivers that's just how it works the way
it works is if you're a good driver you
always use your turn signal you're
always paying attention doing a good job
you are subsidizing bad drivers because
the your the rates are gonna go up for
everybody when you can't figure out
who's the good driver who's the bad
driver
well what if good drivers didn't have to
pay for the bad drivers route insurance
thinks that the old way of pricing car
insurance is unfair so they developed a
mobile app that measures driving
behavior I really love it I love that
they're bringing a new way of thinking
to the car insurance market by by
removing bad drivers from the equation
routes save good drivers up to 52
percent in 2019 52 percent in 2019 route
was the fastest growing direct insurance
company in the u.s. it is the world's
first mobile first car insurance company
they base their rates primarily on how
you drive not on who you are right on
how you're actually driving it's
supercool route the route insurance card
is available right from your phone if
you get into an accident you can file a
claim directly from the app it makes a
whole lot of sense
very very simple it's just look as
technology evolves sometimes certain
industries get stuck in the old way of
doing things and they don't take
advantage of new technology root is
innovating they are leading the way all
you have to do download the root
Insurance app drive normally for a few
weeks during the route test drive see
how much you can save give route a try
go to the App Store and download the
route insurance app sign up in less the
minute to start your test drive today
that is Roo T again download the route
app today or visit join route com to
learn more and see how much you could
save
root reserves the right to refuse to
quote any individual premium rate for
the insurance advertised here in savings
based on National Review supported by
actual customers form one not available
in all states this product is not
available in California threats ok good
news from President Trump here or from
drum and four Trump the good news is
this jobs report what happened in the
November jobs report you probably
haven't read about it very many places
266 thousand new jobs created
unemployment at a forty nine year low
12-month wage growth is at three point
one percent very very strong 54,000
manufacturing jobs created black and
Hispanic unemployment at or near record
lows you couldn't ask for more good news
right pretty much every single box you
could check everything is doing great
this is great news and it really matters
on the cultural front if politics were
merely downstream of culture those
numbers wouldn't matter right because
you wouldn't who cares about the the
political events that's not going to
shape the future the only thing that's
going to shape the future is movies
right if politics were merely downstream
of culture but guess what putting food
on the table is a cultural issue having
a job at when your husband under your
father or you know when when when you
have a job or when someone in your
family has a job that creates dignity
that makes you feel dignity that raises
everybody up that is a cultural
matter those things those cultural
changes in this case are coming by way
of politics just look at the black and
hispanic unemployment numbers right and
then look at the black and hispanic
approval ratings of President Trump
right now there are there was a major
poll that came out last week that
everson poll would show the black
support of President Trump is thirty
four and a half percent is that poll
accurate I don't know I mean that's a
that's a very high number other polls
have backed this up though
NPR Marist Poll was showing the black
and Hispanic support of Trump is pretty
high Rasmussen poll showed the same
thing that is strictly political right
and yet if those numbers hold Democrats
are in huge trouble at the national
level Democrats need to get about 90% of
the black vote to maintain their
electoral position if they lose that if
Republicans get 15 percent of the black
vote forget about 20 percent 25 percent
thirty four and a half percent
it's over for the Democrats if the
Democrats lose their stranglehold on
black voters that's a big political
problem for them but that's a cultural
shift as well a huge cultural shift if
you if you were to crack up this kind of
racially homogeneous voting among say
black voters or to a lesser degree
Hispanic voters that is a major cultural
shift that that speaks very well of our
political process some libertarian
minded conservatives like to pretend
that politics can never have a positive
effect on culture right so what they do
is they admit that politics affects the
culture but they'll say oh it only
destroys culture politics can only
destroy the culture can never fix the
culture that's obviously not true the
Trump administration has had a good
effect on culture in many ways the
Reagan administration had a very good
effect on culture in many ways a lot of
people will tell you from the Reagan era
Reagan defeated the Soviet Union amazing
Reagan fix the economy amazing but one
thing they'll tell you Ronald Reagan
made us all feel good about ourselves
again made us feel good to be Americans
that is a cultural fact that is a
morning in America as his ad famously
said so once you grant that that
politics can have a good effect on the
culture once you grant that then you've
got to ask what is the role of politics
in these social questions this has
become a big point of contention
specifically in regard to the internet
porn debate which we will get to I don't
want to start with internet porn I want
to start with $120,000 banana but before
we get to that I have got to speak about
an intersection of politics and culture
- which is happening in the movie
theaters and theaters right now
nationwide you can go see no safe spaces
which if you look at the poster it says
that it's starring Adam Carolla and
Dennis Prager but we know that that's
not true we know that it's starring me
because I am in the movie for about six
seconds Adam and Dennis take you on a
wild ride in this movie to show you the
effects of political correctness
identity politics and cancel culture it
takes you through the colleges it shows
you the impact on obviously college
campuses but also big tech also in
Hollywood no safe spaces shows us why
free speech is so important to a free
society how it's being threatened what
we can do to fight back this is not a
typical documentary okay
it has animation it has recreations it
has a lot of Adams just hilarious
typical humor which is really really
great we had Adam come on the backstage
show the other day and we you know it's
like we couldn't even get a word out we
were laughing so much no safe spaces
takes you behind the scenes on Ben
Shapiro's riot field trip to UC Berkeley
jeremy boring the god-king the daily
wire as a cameo and then of course you
will find me in the film - it's really
really great go check it out I think
you're you're absolutely going to love
it my father saw it this weekend over in
Connecticut it's all over the country is
rated pg-13 in theaters now go - no safe
spaces dot-com slash Noel's game wles
for ticket information and theater
locations you're really gonna love it
all right I want to talk before we get
to internet porn I want to talk about a
banana and duct tape to a wall because
it matters an Art Basel this this
Art Fair that happens all over the world
this time in Miami a banana duct-taped
to a wall sold as an art piece for
$120,000 the Italian artist
Mauricio Catalan took a banana which
will rot within a week duct-taped it to
a wall and then sold that art piece in
quotes for $120,000 now there were three
of these pieces the third banana is is
expected to sell for $150,000 and then
here's my favorite part of it all right
after it's sold a performance artist
named David de tuna ate the banana
he ate the banana because he was hungry
so some guy buys this banana duct-taped
to a wall for $120,000 because he's an
idiot and then David de tuna eats his
banana this shows us a major problem
with our culture a culture that spends
120 thousand dollars on bananas taped
the walls a culture that considers have
banana taped to a wall to be art has
lost its sense of the meaning of the
word art it has lost its sense of beauty
it has lost its sense of what is good
and what is true another one of these a
a portrait
apparently hyper-realistic portrait I'm
not going to subject you to looking at
it of a channing tatum's private area
went up on eBay it sold for $6,600 this
was done by an LA artist contemporary
art is terrible generally speaking with
that with very few exceptions is
terrible the paintings the movies that
plays the novels and the buildings now
politics is downstream of culture okay
but can politics play a role here of
course it can I'm not saying we have to
ban bananas tape to walls though maybe
that wouldn't be a such a terrible idea
but I don't think we have to do that but
just think about the role of politics in
art think about the buildings I was in
Grand Central the other day I was in New
York
GrandCentral one of the most beautiful
buildings in all of New York maybe the
most beautiful building in New York
grammed huge gorgeous it's it's made in
the Bozarth style it's got beautiful
intricate design and ornamentation and
it's big and it's grand and that's
central compare that to the Freedom
Tower the New World Trade Center
building is ugly it's an ugly building
it's nothing what is it it's nothing
it's a big glass rectangle cool great
nothing permanent about it nothing
enduring nothing beautiful it's just a
big box where people can do work the
city is paying for asked certainly for
parts of both of these buildings and for
maintenance and for security compare the
old Penn Station people don't remember
this the old Penn Station in New York
one of the most beautiful buildings in
New York grand beautiful when you walked
in there you felt like you were a kin
arriving then there's a new Penn Station
which has that monstrosity Madison
Square Garden on top of it when you walk
in there you feel like you're a rat
scurrying around underground just trying
to get to where you're going so you can
run in your little treadmill for long
enough and then go back home and sit in
your other tiny little box those
buildings or works of art okay they're
funded by the government they really
affect our lives we know that money
affects our lives obviously we can buy
things for our friends and family Beauty
affects our lives too when you're in a
beautiful place you feel better you feel
more at ease you feel more contemplative
you can raise your head up to higher
cultural questions and ultimately to
higher religious questions imagine if
the Supreme Court building in Washington
DC imagine if that just looked like a
regular office building like a modern
late twentieth century just glass and
steel and nothing nice about it no
ornamentation to the box that would
affect the Supreme Court it would affect
our government there would be no sense
of weight no seriousness no history no
tradition to that building the
government has to build public buildings
it's it's not a libertarian question of
does the government have to be involved
there should be no public buildings
there should be no government
should never interfere in any piece of
architecture it does the government does
that it has a role to play in the
building of public buildings since it
does the question we have to ask is what
should conservatives ask from this and
conservatives should ask the government
to make beautiful buildings we have a
role we want beauty we we know that the
government does affect the culture we
know that the politics does whether you
want it to or not it does so we need to
make sure that in so much as politics
affects the culture it's got to do it in
a good way what else do we see a role
for when it comes to politics in the
culture a Florida woman is in a modern
relationship I call it and I'm not
saying she's in a same-sex marriage no
she's in a relationship with I guess
it'd be called a quintuple she's in a
relationship romantic relationship with
four men she's pregnant she doesn't know
who the the father is that's modern
that's love is love that's to be
celebrated we'll get to that in a second
first I've got to thank our friends over
at Rock Auto rockauto.com is a family
business serving Auto Parts customers
online for 20 years go to Rock Auto
dot-com to shop for auto and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers look I
know very little about cars other than I
like them and I like to go fast in them
this was about two three months ago I
broke down on the drive up from LA to
San Francisco now you go and you try to
get the auto parts what's so weird about
shopping for auto parts as you go to a
store they don't have the part they just
go online and they charge you a huge
markup you don't need to do that you can
do it yourself it's so easy to navigate
Rocco Doe has everything from engine
control modules and brake parts to tail
lamps motor oil and even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or your
daily driver you get everything you need
in a few easy clicks delivered directly
to your door the thing especially I love
about the rockauto.com catalog is that
it is super easy to navigate you can see
all the available parts for your car you
can choose the brand specifications and
prices you prefer amazing selection
reliably low prices rockauto.com go
there right now see all the parts
available for your
our truck right Knowles Kanna wles in
there how did you hear about us box so
that they know that we sent you rock
Auto calm head on over a Florida woman
is in a quintuple with four men this was
just chronicled on a show called love
don't judge here she is this is Tori she
fell in love with Travis and Ethan and
Mark and Chris there for a relationship
is working wonders for them a
relationship could best be described by
HIV Tori as the hub and all of us are
spokes on the drive wheel but not
everyone understands the dynamic I was
like oh you're kidding
then you're joking how will this poly
relationship cope with a further
addition to the family and so who's the
father of the baby
[Music]
oh you think that's weird
oh you think that's maybe not the best
thing and how dare you you bigot how
intolerant of you how phobic and ISM
that is both ISM and phobic that you're
doing of course not of course not this
is a cultural issue right this woman is
in a romantic relationship that she
wants to be recognized culturally in one
presumes politically with four men
simultaneously they're having a child
together or they don't know who the
father of the baby is there is a role
for government here the government has a
an interest in protecting children the
government has an interest in having a
definition of marriage the government
has an interest in this kind of social
madness how did this come about
if seven years ago eight years ago you
had said that this would be chronicled
that that this woman would have a
relationship with four guys I think a
lot of people would have said yeah maybe
there are a lot of weird people
especially no disrespect intended but
especially in Florida you see a lot of
headlines right except something
fundamentally changed about seven years
ago which is that we redefined marriage
for the first time ever we fundamentally
redefined marriage from a relationship
between husbands and wives to anything
goes we had a definition of marriage
that had endured in the West for all of
certainly recent memory but for our
civilization which is that one man
marries one woman and they have children
together now that has broken down we've
expanded the definition of marriage to
include monogamous same-sex unions why
monogamous if the whole argument for
redefining marriage to include
monogamous same-sex unions is love is
love and how dare you judge and the
heart wants what the heart wants then
who are you to exclude this woman and
her four creepy boyfriends from marriage
doesn't make any sense
there will be a political push to
legalize polygamy there already is in
some quarters and there is no limiting
principle on the Supreme Court's crazy
decision to redefine marriage because
Justice Kennedy woke up and felt like a
Romantic poet one day so there will be a
major push for this and that is a
political issue obviously marriage our
families our cultural primarily but
there is a huge political aspect to this
there will be an answer what is marriage
there will be an end there will be a
political answer to that and if we
decide to blow open the doors to
marriage which in many ways we've
already done that is going to have
cultural effects you know you say well
that's crazy that's fringe that's not
gonna happen anytime soon look at drag
queen story our remember drag queen
story our that this just burst on the
scene like two months ago and it's this
weird thing we're at libraries they
bring in drag queens to perform
sexualized routines for young children
we said that's insane
some more libertarian minded defenders
of this said well who cares it's not
that many of them it's at libraries this
is a blessing of Liberty all right I
guess we need to redefine blessing maybe
we need to redefine Liberty or more
clearly define it but obviously this
libertine ism is never content to remain
where it is it wants to go further so in
Montreal now technically not America but
it's America's hat and what you see
there is coming here to drag queens
story our has left the libraries and
it's headed straight to daycare this is
what one of the organizers of daycare
drag queens story hour wrote on Twitter
it's guy named dan Kravitz quote I'm
proud to have helped organize a drag
queen story hour at our local child
daycare within these children we inspire
a love of reading while teaching deeper
lessons on diversity self-love and
tolerance of others you know a lot of
the the recent debate on the right
between the libertarians and the more
traditionalist types is over whether
there's a role for government to say you
know drag queen story our for little
kids that's a little bit too far maybe
we need some regulations on this maybe
we need some laws and then the
libertarians say no any laws regulating
any social question or is completely
unacceptable where the rubber meets the
road on this question is internet porn
my colleague Matt Walsh kicked a beehive
the other day when he said he wants to
ban internet porn massive debate going
on online I will give you the correct
answer to that debate we'll do that in a
second first I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube
so you lookyou you like our new set
right you like our new studio it's
looking pretty good
well all of this requires money folks
you know they obviously they don't pay
me but they at least need to keep the
lights on so please head on over to
daily wire coms subscribe you can become
now and all access to your member which
means that you can engage in these
conversations that we do regularly on
the new website on the new app it looks
super cool obviously you get me the
bench bureau show the amber claim and
show the Matt wall show you get to ask
questions the mailbag you get another
Kingdom you get the leftist years tumblr
all very important stuff head to daily
wire.com we'll be right back
all right this all comes down to
internet porn it's where it all comes
welcome they say sex sells so we're now
at the the sex portion of the show the
culture is moving radically left at an
increasing rate okay you're that woman
with the four dudes that's going to be a
political debate very soon if it isn't
already drag queens story hour is
certainly a political manner now and
porn is where a lot of this is being
fought I frankly I think it's a cause of
a lot of the confusion Matt Walsh kicked
off this kerfuffle on the Internet
when he said we need to ban porn and we
should jail pornographers this elicited
outrage from the more libertarian minded
segments of the right okay
the there's a writer for the DC Examiner
of Brad Palumbo Palumbo he tweeted out
quote new rule all the young trad con
dudes tweeting about how they support
porn bands must post their unredacted
web browsing history okay this is the
kind of typical response of the more
libertarian minded people which is hey
you think that we should regulate
something that's bad have you ever done
that bad thing well then you have no
standing here because you're a hypocrite
no first of all first of all hypocrisy
is the tribute vice pays to virtue but
further beyond seeing in this a kind of
contradiction ha some guy looked at
internet porn like all guys have done in
America well then you can never say that
internet porn is bad rather than seeing
a contradiction maybe we should see a
cause here okay
amalia holla kiyose posted on twitter
very accurately quote it's obvious the
porn is fine plus you can't stop me haha
chortle twitter shrieking is not
representative of the dominant male view
which is quote yes i watch porn it's
gross it's bad for me I should probably
stop this seems much clearer to me you
know
who knows more about the dangerous
effects of crystal meth some guy who's
got his life in order whose job it is to
think and write in a nice
air-conditioned beautiful room on the
Potomac or a meth addict probably the
meth addict knows what's better you know
I noticed the people clamoring for say
the total legalization of drugs like
heroin or crystal meth they're never the
people who are hooked on heroin or
crystal meth it's always people who have
really abstract ideological views of
politics whose lives are basically in
order that doesn't doesn't seem to make
a whole lot of sense to me you know Ben
domenech at the Federalist he tweeted at
a similar version I think a better
objection to the calls to ban porn but
still not sufficient he tweeted out
quote or the Conservatives who think
they can ban porn online purposefully
ignoring the massive expansion of
government this would require or are
they too stupid to realize it this is
another example where social
conservatives should work to reestablish
cultural stigmas which are far more
powerful and enduring than government
regulation so he's making the argument
the politics is simply downstream of
culture you can't really affect the
culture in a good way with the politics
and juries how crazy it would be to jail
pornographers we could never do that
except we do that and we've done that
recently which perhaps been for God and
I think a lot of conservatives forgot
we've been we've prosecuted hardcore
pornographers as recent as 2008 we sent
them to jail as recently as 2009 in 2008
in Tampa Florida guy named Paul little
who goes by the name max hardcore this
guy's like out of a movie it's this guy
his name is actually hardcore and we're
talking about hardcore pornography is
the real central problem here he was
found guilty of distributing obscene
material over the Internet not kiddie
porn by the way not something that's you
know we all consider to be illegal he
was found guilty of distributing obscene
material through the u.s. mail and over
the Internet he was sentenced to 40
months in prison here's a writer in
Forbes magazine describing what the
usual max hardcore scene looks like
quote his formulaic movies focused on
the systematic degradation of his female
co-star of the moment who was not
infrequently dressed up to resemble a
child wearing pigtails discovered on a
playground sucking on a lollipop the sex
scenes took place on what would become
an iconic yellow sofa where speculums
were introduced hardcores verbal
onslaughts commenced and the young women
were turned into wild-eyed days to
zombies by the finale okay that seems
pretty obscene that seems pretty bad
doesn't seem good for the Conservatives
or so-called conservatives who are
saying if you're a conservative we need
to support ubiquitous hardcore porn and
if you think that we shouldn't have
ubiquitous hardcore porn and you think
maybe we should use politics to stop it
you're not a real conservative I think
what that shows is that the meaning of
the word conservative has drifted way
too far
when conservatism is boiled down or
redefined to just mean libertine ism if
not outright anarchy you've gone too far
you've redefined conservatism too much
why is porn bad why is it bad
nobody thinks it's good okay first of
all I don't I don't think I actually
need to convince people that widespread
hardcore internet porn is bad okay do
you know how I know that internet porn
is bad and that everyone thinks that
internet porn is bad because of the
incognito window because there is
actually a function now built into every
web browser that allows you to hide what
you're doing when you look at internet
porn do you do you go and you kind of
open up the window shades and you say oh
hey there neighbors how you know how me
I'm just gonna go look at a bunch of
really gross internet porn you can take
a look if you want yeah I'll just be
over here doing that thing that I am so
ashamed to do that I have to turn the
lights off close the door and you know
put on earphones and put a towel
underneath the door so nobody can hear
anything
yeah that's but it's really good though
it's really it's a great thing it's
totally fine a blessing of Liberty no I
don't think so
what is porn do internet porn degrades
people
it specifically degrades the women who
are in the scenes
right it obviously degrades the
performers it treats human beings who
have intellect and will who are higher
than the animals it treats them as
brutes and it treats them as objects
it literally objectifies people that
turns them into nothing more than their
flesh which is crazy to think about to
think about how much time people spend
looking at internet porn when really all
you're watching is just pieces of flesh
bump into each other and we all get
titillated about that because we also
have a sexual nature it degrades the
performance it also degrades the viewers
because you've got to be that guy who
goes into the room and turns the lights
down and locks the door and closes the
blinds every watch is that thing and
does that thing that doesn't look very
dignified or cool
that's the degradation problem it's also
ubiquitous it's everywhere and it's
viewed by children 93 percent of boys
and 62 percent of girls report seeing
porn before age 18 and I would add to
that study 7 percent of boys are liars
so I would guess it's even a little
higher than 93 percent ok the average
age of first internet porn exposure
today do you know what the ages 11 it's
the average age 10% of kids under the
age of 10 have seen porn why else is
porn bad highly addictive it has long
lasting effects on your brain it is
leading to skyrocketing rates of
erectile dysfunction among young men men
in their 20s who should be active who
should be virile
they're now suffering from edie like
their Bob Dole of the 90s it also has
long lasting effects on your soul that's
a question for another day
it's also disgusting it's just gross
right it's the porn is gross I think the
people who watch the porn which is
statistically like every guy in America
but hopefully there's a movement now to
really fight back against this so I hope
that number is going down you know
especially when the internet was first
invented like everybody was doing it
I think only now are we seeing that the
dangerous and deleterious effects of it
the porn itself is disgusting but the
very fact that everybody is looking at
internet porn all the time is disgusting
in itself because it makes us a nation
of wankers and you don't
to be a nation of wankers because that's
sad and pathetic all right this is a
very tough issue it's actually a very
tough issue not in the clarity of it I
think we all know it's bad it's gross
it's new it's highly addictive our
brains were not built to handle this and
we have a kind of vaguely libertarian
politics at least the right has
convinced itself to become libertarian
in recent decades and that's made the
problem a lot harder virtually
everybody's looked at the stuff it's
very addictive it would be good to
discourage it right this was common
sense until we through common sense out
the window so can the government that is
the first question is porn bad yeah we
should all agree with that
and if you don't agree with that I think
you're kidding yourself right you've got
an industry that exploits like 18 year
old runaway girls and turns them into
nothing more than flesh that's not a
good industry the next question is can
the government do something about it the
libertarian immediately says no oh god
heaven forfend clutch your pearls yeah
of course the government can do
something about that we regulate
gambling booze and tobacco on the
internet you need to prove that you're
21 to buy a pack of cigarettes online
when I try to buy cigars online it's
difficult it should not be difficult
all right I'm oh we also should make it
easier to buy cigars online it's a issue
for another day you need an ID to buy a
playboy
if you go up to a magazine rack so why
is everybody so frazzled about the
prospect of applied in the exact same
regulations that we have for cigarettes
and nudie mags - internet porn
doesn't make a whole lot of sense there
is no constitutional right to internet
porn okay there's this common objection
to regulating porn which is that it's
unamerican
to regulate foreign what are you talking
about we have had obscenity laws in this
country forever we currently have
obscenity laws in this country we
through pornographers in jail under
those obscenity laws ten years ago it
look you might not like it you might say
well we got to get rid of those
obscenity laws okay but don't tell me
it's unamerican it's completely
perfectly American the country was was
founded by we're
zealot Puritans who left England for
Leiden and left Leiden for America and
practiced a very very puritanical form
of Christianity which I am not
advocating but you can't say it's on
American you know there's this common
objection I think it's one of the the
most pernicious lies that people have
bought into in politics which is that
you can't legislate morality that's what
you hear you can't legislate morality of
course you can not only can you you must
you cannot legislate without legislating
morality
we exclusively legislate morality how do
what do I mean by that when you're
arguing about tax rates something is
basic and boring those tax rates you are
using moral arguments you're saying well
I have a right to my property and I have
some duty to the government but because
of my property rights I should keep more
of my property when you're arguing about
health care those are moral arguments
we're on the right side of history we
need to extend modern medical technology
to everybody because that is good and
right and just then the other side of
the argument will say how dare you
you're totalitarian you're stealing my
money you were infringing on my Liberty
which is a god-given right now I'm gonna
keep my Liberty those are they're both
making moral arguments everybody makes
the moral argument when it comes to
health care and everything else parking
tickets laws governing parking tickets
involve moral arguments the rights to
public land the rights to private
property you do legislate morality right
when it comes to high-speed internet
porn it's a new problem it's a major
social problem and has victims it's
affecting people's health especially
young men it's more or less completely
unregulated now there's double standards
when it comes to other kinds of
pornography and gambling and other vices
and it's making us a bunch of wankers do
not be a wanker that's not a good
country to have if you are a wanker go
to confession and try to stop but at the
very least forget the personal question
just from social
spective from a political perspective we
don't want to be a nation of wankers so
we should take these questions seriously
before we go I've got to get to Katy
Hill speaking of creepy creepy sex
you remember Katy Hill she is that
former congressman who was involved in a
throuple with her husband and a female
staffer who was right out of college and
she sexually exploited this staffer and
she put her on the payroll and she
dumped her and she moved her away and
the staffer was heartbroken if Katy Hill
were a man this would be the biggest sex
abuse sexual harassment case in all of
Congress or if Katy Hill were
Republicans same thing but because she's
a Democrat woman they're trying to make
her seem like a victim
the New York Times absolutely shameless
publishes an op-ed Katie Hill it's not
over after all I overcame the
desperation I felt after stepping down
from Congress and I'm still in the fight
here's what she writes on November 6
2018 I was elected to Congress at 31 I
was one of the youngest women ever
elected to the House of Representatives
one year later I was sitting on a train
to New York to meet with my lawyers
about suing the Daily Mail for cyber
exploitation and I was no longer a
member of Congress suing because she's a
victim she stepped up to a microphone it
was the first time I had spoken publicly
since my relationship with a campaign
staffer was exposed to the naked photos
of me taken without my knowledge and
distributed without my consent had been
posted online since wild accusations
from my estranged husband about a
supposed affair with a congressional
staffer which I've repeatedly divided
since I had resigned my hard-fought seat
in Congress no notice she doesn't
actually deny the allegations she says
that she has denied them but she doesn't
say they're not true why cuz they're
obviously true and by the way she
obviously knew the photos were being
taken she's looking at the camera in
many of the photos so that's a lie - she
goes on that day oddly I didn't get
nervous the way I normally did I got
every part of the routine right I felt
common strong as I began to speak
because I had to be I needed to say
something to the countless people who
had put their faith in me I needed to
say something to the girls and young
women who looked up to me I needed to
make sure that my horrific experience
did not frighten and discourage other
women who will dare to take risks dare
to step into this light dare to be
powerful Katie hill should dare to take
a seat sit down sit this one out
we've been told for a very long time
that shunning our moral responsibilities
shunning our conscience shunning our
duties to one another shunning dignity
is empowering that's good it's what we
should strive for overcome your
conscience follow your will exert your
will on others that's essentially the
case made by Katie Hill that's the case
made by the left that's a recipe for a
terrible terrible Society we have to fix
that we have to fix that through movies
we have to fix that through plays we
have to fix that through art and culture
we also have to fix that in our politics
Katie Hill is a political figure
she needs to suffer political
consequences for what she's done and he
need to acknowledge a politics that will
acknowledge the culture there will make
politics downstream of culture once
again that's our show I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Dole show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]